hello and welcome to this will play not
kovitch testing a little bit of that c4
repertoire there was working on oh ok so
i get this line again which I recently
head on the body on the asus eee where i
won a nice game let's see what not
kovitch is coming up with taking there
ok that's interesting i can take only
for with the with the pawn I really
don't know it looks interesting d takes
you for ism um yeah it's not if I really
had on the radar so we should f5 ok if
he takes on d1 contigs f2 with Hank so
mmm we should be 3s 94 which is pretty
irritating well III is not a dream move
very bit ok
yeah I one day ft five is good it
neglects development but it's lots of
space okay it's probably not essential
to do it right away f1 1085 and it's
interesting let's do it its aggressive
but these are three center pawns are
close to Center plans going forward we
are Knight b6 maybe to have a safe night
to d5 in case of the e4 if i push that
looks fairly logical yep
yeah maybe I should should have thought
about this for a moment but ok it's not
a big problem I can still do this and
play h3g for next now let's put it's a
really nice position this pieces don't
do anything and this big majority is
completely immobile even g4s coming into
consideration yeah we're not actually 45
so I'm going to be able to push it to h5
but I think wait wait when he's got c5
coming maybe ok I think I should do this
get it to h5 in case i'll see if i have
notes it to what's not a big thing can
also go to f5 ok anyway the Queen cannot
stay on the tool for the rest of the
games are going to put it here yeah if I
494 I would be cool yeah let's do it
94 to go to 95 or something yeah maybe
you also go fo and we should be three
it's also interesting I would like to
use that bishop at some point now now
that looks good we should be three look
81 use all the pieces should age three
coming huh maybe okay Queen g3 doesn't
really do much what else can I do here I
can also play f5 hmm but if five is
hanging okay push it
Kinji for Queen f three years good check
it should be okay I've got a lot lots
more space IAM maybe there was more
that's very very very much possible but
it's not bad let's see wants to go 95-93
I guess ok it's on vacation or SF b 3
like to go at five somehow ok and I now
see what the real issue is and download
it 30 seconds
k
okay no he's taking time
okay yeah so b3 Bishop before is
probably the thing try to prepare that
what I just overlook this one that's not
good time learning God now it's called
rocket III playing miracle moves all the
time probably mt3 Wow unbelievable for
bishops five maybe doc I can still take
wow what a strange game and the strange
position right 916 check I can go
night-night back Wow whoa check
ah what a nonsensical game check nice
[ __ ] Bishop t6 unfortunately a shoot
let's lad flexisign counting on time Ian
chair while no I had spotted this
position around here why doesn't
fantastic shape got lots more space by
the center but maybe maybe four wasn't
that good after all I don't know I still
like it not before was still turning to
her jumping right in something that is
pretty funny porns structure but it's
definitely good for wider I'm having
lots of space at five and so on Jim but
it probably wasn't that bad here either
Jack he caught some something he got
something here I probably have to play
differently he rocked it was probably
wrong the only idea that he has a snotty
three but it's a serious idea the
computer suggests this so that after 93
I can go be three ad yet why does a lot
better a note that he has no space at
all this was the problem problem here
he'll be three I cannot play because of
Bishop before i was thinking of
but even that is good for what okay so
yeah I'd simply simply blundered between
him yeah this route d3 is it just it is
just good in here and probably lost them
check okay night f8 also even stronger
check check yeah can we scrambled on and
i won on time which was not very
deserving she look at the position i had
a very good position out of the opening
go now okay i'm happy with the win
thanks for watching